each year in July tens of thousands of
motorcycle fans converge on
garmisch-partenkirchen for the BMW
motorrad days where they talk shop and
party through the weekend the unofficial
star of this year's event was 81 year
old sub vinta and is over 60 years on
the road he's collected 23 two wheelers
he's been a motorcycle enthusiast since
his youth he got his driver's license in
1950 and drove a 200cc German Victoria
in 1953 he bought a new adlon and in
1954 a 500cc BMW his favorite is the r50
he says the engine runs like a dream and
has a much better pick up than the 250
CC engines it's entirely different and
lots of fun on the road he's all this
fun is over
daddy roars up nothing frail about this
old man all eyes are on set and his are
50 as they take their place at the head
of the pack right behind the police
escort sep seems to enjoy being the
center of attention this is his 15
minutes of fame motorcycle riders have
to know what they're doing to live as
long as sep eric a motorbike instructor
explains what to do if your machine
unexpectedly tips over
you don't see where you go is difficult
and I can leave the back with one leg
because I don't do have forward one
legacy
before I do mean by my leg since my
booty
the motorcycle fans came from all over
Europe many of them are veteran bikers
with thousands of kilometers behind them
the biker and his bike might stay
together for decades BMW itself can
boast of over 90 years of rich and
successful motorcycling history in the
1920s BMW sports model r37 collected
honors on the racetrack including three
class victories in its first time around
BMW made the 16 horsepower r37 available
to private buyers in 1925 the racing
cycles kept getting lower and lower BMWs
boxer engine was ideally suited to this
design seen here on the 1972 rs500 BMW
won the Iowa man tourist trophy nine
times and the german championship six
times BMW won the paris-dakar rally
again and again through the 1980s and in
1998 made a new start with a single
cylinder model based on the f650 Beemer
scored its biggest success in the year
2000 taking both first and fourth places
in the Dakar Rally rookie writers can
lose their training wheels on this 2010
BMW s1000rr fim superstock it puts out
142 kilowatts at some thirteen thousand
rpms riders must be under 24 years old
the motor odd days even have something
for absolute beginner bikers like milena
art and a closed-off space she can
sample the feel of the open road even
without a motorcycle license if it's in
this town smallest seemed to come to my
place done I wish been slowly well you
know it's never driven a motorcycle
before she wants to see if she can do it
she gets a few pointers and she's off on
her first lap even if driving instructor
godfried Medicus keeps his hand on the
machine as a safety precaution letting
milena concentrate on learning to ride
now she can feel the power she's sitting
on and knows better than to
underestimated she's a bit stressed but
still having fun for her or anyone who's
never done it it takes quite a lot of
getting used to here to a little courage
and self confidence will go a long way
in just a few minutes milena has godfre
jogging along beside her yuck it makes
her feel happy she says it's like a
dream she can imagine that driving a
motorcycle properly would be incredible
she wouldn't mind giving it a try
freshly / toughie
with a stunt show Monty Griffin of
Ireland takes the spectators breath away
sitting standing on two wheels or one
he's perfected the art of motorcycle
riding
Ron's from the Netherlands BMW
motorcycle club sums up the whole event
in a few words BMW motorcycles have a
model for everyone he says it's great
fantastic or in Dutch poor dobby while
indicas are qld